tant que j'aurai pas la preuve de sa
mort je chercherai qu'elle chercherait
c'est un mystère qui intrigue encore
aujourd'hui la sphère dupont de ligonnès
ce sont des années d'enquêté de fausses
pistes
le 21 avril 2011 il ya tout juste dix
ans cinq corps d'une même famille sont
retrouvés sous la terrasse d'une maison
nantaise
jusque là la famille semblait s'être
volatilisé les téléphones fait plus
aucun mouvement sur les comptes
bancaires
aucune trace ni dans les aéroports ni
dans les gares et sur la boîte aux
lettres une invitation à renvoyer le
courrier le père de famille xavier
dupont de ligonnès est introuvable
tous les soupçons se portent sur lui l'
enquête démarre les policiers tentent de
retracer son parcours avant le meurtre
le suspect est passé par nantes toulouse
puis le pontet dans le vaucluse quelques
jours avant la découverte des corps il y
passe une nuit dans un hôtel cinq
étoiles
c'était quelqu'un de très très
sympathique du souriant affable passe
préfet du doubs n'a vraiment montré
aucun signe de l'irritation l'énervement
de tensions après le comte et xavier
dupont de ligonnès se rend à
roquebrune-sur-argens dans le var
c'est là qu'il est pris en photo à un
distributeur pour la dernière fois le 14
avril 2011
puis les policiers perdent sa trace
l'enquète s'enlise pendant des années
jusqu'au 29 avril 2015
c'est à un promeneur qui a fait la
macabre découverte hier soif des
ossements humains mais aussi des objets
sont découverts en forêt près de fréjus
dans le var
c'est tout proche du lieu où a disparu
xavier dupont de ligonnès donc mon
excluons rien et nous mettons les moyens
pour identifier ce malheureux défunt
après rien ne nous dit aujourd'hui que
c'est lui non plus c'est une fausse
piste
l'enquète stagne encore avant d'être
relancé en janvier 2018
des témoins auraient aperçu xavier
dupont de ligonnès dans un monastère à
roquebrune-sur-argens une opération de
police a lieu une fois de plus c'est une
impasse il a été vu en vie aboud soir
jean-louis les jaser mais ça c'est ok
mold it prototype je n'en sais
absolument rien là on est vraiment en
danger réel
voilà c'est presque de la fiction 2019
nouveau rebondissement et énième fausse
piste ans retraité soupçonné d'être
xavier dupont de ligonnès est arrêté à
l'aéroport de glasgow en ecosse mais
pour les voisins de l'homme interpellé
aucun doute il ne s'agit pas du suspect
numéro un
c'est une monumentale comme monumentale
erreur ça fait 30 ans qu'on est à 89
j'ai acheté ma maison en 89 ans 89 et
c'est là qu'on s'est connus aujourd'hui
xavier dupont de ligonnès reste toujours
introuvable depuis sa disparition en
il a fait l'objet de plus de 1000
signalement
[Musique]